creo que ahorita es un muy buen momento
para enfrentar una pregunta que seguro
ha estado rondando por tu cabeza y esto
es que le pasó al oro recuerda que
cuando empezamos todo esto de los bancos
de los bancos nacionales los bancos
tenían oro como reserva después dijeron
nada pues para qué estamos haciendo esto
para que tenemos oro en nuestras bóvedas
vamos a meter todo en un mismo banco en
un mismo banco de la reserva ese banco
luego podría emitir notas bancarias y
esas notas bancarias pues ya en el fondo
son las que se pueden intercambiar por
oro con el paso del tiempo pues la gente
se empezó a acostumbrar a usar estas
notas bancarias sin creo que eso está
muy grueso a usar los billetes por sí
mismos como el material de reserva si
verdad a partir de un momento ya
utilizamos esas reservas para calcular
el coeficiente de reserva y dijimos que
si el banco federal
quisiera aumentar la capacidad de
préstamo entonces podría imprimir nuevos
billetes lo de siempre imprimen nuevos
billetes entonces ahora tiene un pasivo
correspondiente de notas bancarias
pendientes y luego puede utilizar esos
billetes para realizar operaciones en el
mercado abierto
de modo que en el fondo pues pueda
manejar la oferta de dinero según estén
los proyectos así en el mundo para que
se puedan apoyar si te das cuenta en
toda esta discusión este metal así
amarillos o todo el tiempo estuvo
reposando en las bóvedas y no tuvo nada
que ver con la economía bueno siendo
honestos la verdad si tuvo un poquito
que ver que haya algo de confianza en
estos papelitos que decidimos imprimir
sí verdad bueno al menos al inicio de
toda nuestra discusión dijimos que las
notas bancarias estaban respaldadas por
oro y pues no sé o sea podía ser una
cantidad similar de oro o después
dijimos bueno también podemos
intercambiarlas pues a cierto tipo de
cambio digamos de a 35 billetitos por
onza de oro creo que estaba a 35 dólares
en eeuu cuando se salieron del patrón
oro bueno pero si lo piensas un poquito
hay algunas cosas raras detrás de toda
esta idea porque pues para empezar
porque creamos los billetes justo para
tener una moneda que crezca y que crezca
con la economía y entonces tenemos pues
mucho más en otras bancarias que lo que
tenemos respaldado en oro de hecho esto
pasaba incluso antes de salirse del
patrón oro cuando el oro
respaldaba las notas bancarias también
habían más en notas eso sí estamos
manteniendo el oro en las bóvedas en
caso de que la gente crea que estés
faroleando y que x por ciento quiera su
dinero de vuelta y entonces pueda llegar
al banco y pedir su oro fuera de eso
pues fundamentalmente el oro no ayuda en
la economía no ayudó a hacer
transacciones pues no era dinero por sí
mismo simplemente estaba por ahí en una
bóveda secreta y de cierto modo era
mucho más latoso que que tener peso
alguna otra cosa de valor porque pues
porque de cierta forma debes de mantener
esta noción de que estas notas estos
billetes están respaldados en oro y por
tanto estás estableciendo en el fondo un
coeficiente de reserva para el banco de
la reserva central esto parece muy
arbitrario no es un coeficiente que
depende de la cantidad de oro en el
mundo y no sé a lo mejor esto no tiene
tanto sentido del crecimiento se puede
dar por la invención de computadoras o
aviones o nuevas inversiones o
tecnologías de la educación y entonces
si quisiéramos mantener la oferta de
dinero correspondiente a este
crecimiento económico claro y seguimos
en el patrón oro si quisiéramos que la
oferta de dinero fuera al día
en el crecimiento económico entonces
tendríamos que tener más reservas de oro
eso es muy arbitrario no sabemos si
vamos a encontrar mucho oro o no eso no
tendría que ser una barrera para nuestro
avance tecnológico y nuestro trabajo
duro mira a esta otra referencia
imagínate que por alguna razón que hay
un asteroide repleto de oro así en
querétaro como ahora tenemos más oro eso
debería de hacer que el precio del peso
baje pues no verdad o al revés
imagínate que así por alguna razón en el
mundo se extingue todo el oro que está
en el planeta eso debería ser una causa
para impedir que circulemos moneda y
bueno luego se convierten en billetes
pero esto es algo que comenté hace
varios vídeos verdad no sólo son una
responsabilidad del banco central sino
que son una responsabilidad del gobierno
del gobierno federal pues pensarlo como
el gobierno mexicano bueno ahí está una
pregunta preferirías tener algo
respaldado por el oro o algo respaldado
por el gobierno mexicano después de
pensarlo tantito muchos de ustedes van a
decir no pues oro oro por favor el oro
es así valor real mientras que el
gobierno mexicano pues anda en muchos
líos políticos
ubican más la riqueza tienen a cada rato
un problema que termina con gates pero
piénsalo tantito como lo habíamos dicho
antes el oro en realidad no es riqueza
el oro representa la riqueza únicamente
porque está bonito y bueno porque no se
corroe pero o sea representa riqueza
porque alguien en el pasado dijo pues
voy a sembrar tu cosecha si me das esa
piedra padrísima que te encontraste ese
es el único valor real del oro no
podemos comérnoslo no podemos vivir a
partir de él en el fondo no es riqueza
real no es riqueza real ahora qué sucede
con el gobierno mexicano bueno para
empezar tiene el derecho o la autoridad
de establecer impuestos ya se impuestos
es una palabra fea la verdad a mí no me
gustan mucho pero bueno quedándonos en
esta idea puede obtener esta renta
estableciendo impuestos a la economía
mexicana economía mexicana y la economía
mexicana la economía mexicana eso sí es
riqueza eso es labor ideas
tierra recursos todo lo que nos late
nuestro labor nuestros bienes y
servicios nuestra capacidad de educarnos
y de educar de hacer innovaciones de
crear tecnología todo esto si es riqueza
es riqueza real y si lo piensas tantito
y ya sé que ahorita estoy siendo un poco
abstracto pero si lo piensas hay mucha
gente que cree que hay como algo que es
intercambiable por el oro así
superimportante que lo hace más valioso
mientras que si es una obligación del
gobierno entonces es algo como que más
más frágil o algo que de alguna forma
está respaldado por menor riqueza pero
yo creo que no que de hecho esto en
realidad es una riqueza más profunda o
sea ve en muchas civilizaciones su
moneda si ha estado respaldada por oro
pero en la mayoría de las ocasiones de
todas formas había inflación no sé por
ejemplo en españa' la moneda española en
el siglo 15 estaba respaldada por oro
que sucede descubren así un montón de
oro en centroamérica esto causa
inflación no genera riqueza y hace que
todo se vuelva más caro para ellos
pero les permitió comprar algunas cosas
de otros países pero no creo nada de
innovación y en realidad no fue que su
pastel se hiciera más grande sino que
podían comprar pasteles más grandes de
otras partes del mundo bueno mucho de
este ejemplo pero esto de acá si es
riqueza real una moneda respaldada de la
habilidad de toda una nación para
generar riqueza en cierto sentido es
mucho más valiosa no ahora sin embargo
el oro si fue una piedra angular para
que todo este sistema funcionara para
que la gente realmente confiar en esta
moneda para que para que para que esto
funcionara pues pues tenías que
convencerlos a partir del oro bueno si
lo piensas tantito como el oro ya no
estaba haciendo nada entonces tenía
mucho sentido que en los países
desarrollados se salieran del patrón oro
siempre y cuando y claro esto es súper
importante siempre y cuando confíes que
el gobierno va a administrar la oferta
de dinero de manera efectiva por ejemplo
que no van a imprimir tanto como para
que haya hiperinflación o tan poquito
para que haya un nada como si se espiral
deflacionaria si confías en la habilidad
del gobierno para controlar eso entonces
no importa que nos hayamos salido del
patrón oro
y de hecho evita esa molestia de las
bóvedas claro si vieras la hoja de
balance del banco federal de países
desarrollados pues aún tienen un poquito
de oro porque la verdad no es obvio qué
hacer con él
bueno después en el futuro vamos a
hablar un poquito más acerca de qué es
la riqueza y que no es pero ahorita como
un ejemplo así sencillito que me gusta
mucho contárselo a las personas
supongamos que eres el piloto de un
avión y así vas y de repente empieza a
sonar
el motor y el avión se va a caer empieza
así a quemarse todo y se va a caer y a
lo lejos en el horizonte vez dos islas
como tu avión se está cayendo entonces
tienes que ir a alguna de esas dos islas
en la primera simplemente hay una pila
enorme de oro
y la enorme ok y en la segunda isla así
desde el telescopio de tu avión puedes
ver que hay algunas vacas y no sé pues
tiene algunos árboles así frutales de
frutas comestibles y además pues puedes
ver un
un gran lago de averno para pintar en
negro un gran lago de petróleo y además
otro lago de agua así agua fresca y
lejos del petróleo para que no se
contamine y también un montón de gente
innovadora y trabajadora inteligente y
trabajadora y no sé que también le gusta
la fiesta y además pues tienen algunas
carreteras por ahí tienen carreteras y
tienen caballos tienen de todo pues
tienen así todo ok en qué isla
preferirías aterrizar suponiendo que no
vas a poder regresar a la civilización
pues creo que la respuesta obvia es
aterrizar el avión en esta isla esta
isla tiene más riqueza bueno entonces
cuando nos salimos del patrón oro pues
si parece ser así una cosa horrible una
cosa no sea horrible para nuestra
economía
de hecho el oro pasó de 35 dólares la
libra a 700 800 o más uno puede pensar
que no hubiéramos tenido tanta inflación
si siguiéramos en el patrón oro pero
piensa un poquito qué ha pasado con la
economía más allá de estas pequeñas
crisis causadas por un exceso de
préstamos hace como 15 o 20 años ha
habido una cantidad increíble de
innovación
nos hemos salvado de la hiperinflación y
mira todo esto lo hemos logrado aunque
la moneda aunque la moneda no está
respaldada así por un metal duro por
algo físico lo hemos logrado simplemente
confiando en que el gobierno mexicano
puede respaldar sus deudas y por tanto
pues puede respaldar la moneda mexicana
en fin vamos a hablar de eso después con
más calma habitada pues no quiero
repetirme demasiado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo ahorita quería platicar
esta idea de que nos salimos del patrón
oro hasta la próxima